police in the brazilian city of rio de
janeiro arrested four people on
wednesday as part of a case involving a
widow her daughter a psychic and
paintings jewelry and cash worth tens of
millions of dollars
a case of fraud and elder abuse
involving 16 priceless works of art
belonging to 82 year old genevieve
bhagisi the wife of the late art
collector jean bojishi
the daughter of the victim and her
accomplice began to take the artwork
from the mother's house claiming that
the painting was cursed with something
negative with negative energy that
needed to be prayed over
knowing that this was not true
sabine kolba jishi was arrested on
accusations of being the alleged
mastermind of a years-long scheme to
defraud her mother
using so-called psychics she swindled
some of brazil's most famous artwork
we concluded in the preliminary check
that all the characteristics of the
seized paintings are compatible with the
authentic paintings
police say sabine and six other suspects
physically threatened genevieve and
forcibly kept her at home for months
the victim went to the police after
almost a year of abuse
four other people were also arrested two
suspects are still at large
all face charges of embezzlement robbery
extortion false imprisonment and
criminal association zenbasravi
al-jazeera